[Musique]
déguster du boudin noir sucré salé comme
au temps du roi soleil
c'est l'expérience culinaire que vos
propos ce restaurant versailles et si
les recettes sont élaborées dans une
cuisine moderne
elles sont toutes puiser au sein de
livres datant du xviie ou xviiie siècle
on peut trouver de la sole de l'arrêt du
perdreau du chevreuil
ce sont des ingrédients qui se
trouvaient sur les tables des rois ou en
tout cas des nobles de la cour de cette
époque et et nous revisitons les
recettes pour les adapter aux goûts du
jour bien évidemment et proposer un menu
haut de gamme mais le concept ne
s'arrête pas là bienvenue dans la cour
intérieure ici vous trouvez la table des
comédiens et c'est ici qu'ils s'amusent
à jouer aux cartes
tout au long de ce repas gastronomique
des saynètes sont joués
histoire de vous plonger encore plus
dans les secrets de la cour de louis xiv
les comédiens viennent à votre table
vous raconter des anecdotes
croustillantes qui ont qui sont
historiques qui ont réellement eu lieu
ou en tout cas rumeurs historique et ils
viennent vraiment au contact proche de
vous c'est un peu comme si vous vous
surprenez une conversation dans les
couloirs du temps entre deux personnages
du xviie ou xviiie siècle en fonction de
la pièce de théâtre que vous choisissez
coût du voyage dans le temps à partir de
100 euros par personne et après un repas
fastueux
rien de tel qu'une petite promenade dans
le potager du roi crée entre 1678 1683 à
la demande de louis xiv féru de
jardinage
il ouvrira ses portes au grand public à
l'occasion de l'événement esprit jardin
parmi les choses de cette époque ci qui
sont excellentes et font nous font du
bien
les épinards des salades construit par
jean baptiste laquintinie le potager du
roi était chargé de fournir en fruits et
légumes la table du roi soleil il est
aujourd'hui classé monument historique
et jardins remarquables
c'est un jardin un grand carré central
avec un bassin des visées en croix sur
les points cardinaux et toute une série
de jardin qui font le tour c'est les
premières représentations du jardin en
occident la particularité de ce jardin
c'est d'avoir maintenu ce dessin de
l'avoir respecté depuis sa création avec
quelques petites modifications
rendez vous les 5 et 6 mai à 15 heures
pour faire un bond dans le passé et
découvrir ce lieu confidentiel
[Musique]